alright and that is the end of the
democratic debate apologies to everybody
that I was not with you for the debate
itself but there is so so so much to be
discussed and the these are surreal
times quite frankly I doing the debate I
learned that the Massachusetts among
four total additional states will be
shutting down bars and restaurants
starting on Tuesday going all the way
through April's April sixth here in
Massachusetts I actually as much as it
is disappointing is a reality that it
probably needs to happen we are under
the leadership of a Republican governor
Charlie Baker who while I didn't vote
for him if I had to pick a Republican
governor to be led by at this point in
time I would choose Charlie Baker before
many others including that absolute
lunatic governor in Oklahoma who was
bragging about being out yesterday with
his kids at some packed restaurant or
whatever
so listen welcome I'm gonna wait a few
minutes for people to join in I have a
bunch of people to thank who signed up
during the pre-show and I want to make
sure I thank everybody and all of that
but essentially I mean my view is
summarized in a tweet which I would love
for you to retweet and you know ratio me
if you're mad or do whatever I mean I
don't even care what people do is it's
Twitter it's not the real world
have at it Hoss but what I said was from
this debate the contrast is unmistakable
Bernie Sanders is solidly to Joe Biden's
left I also cannot imagine that
tonight's debate changes the polling in
Tuesday's primaries where am I wrong and
I invite you of course to find me on
Twitter at Dee Pakman and tell me all of
the ways in which I am completely wrong
but listen the as soon as it became
clear that the focus was going to be
coronavirus to to a great degree it
became clear to me that this played
directly into a Joe Biden's advantage in
the sense that this is an area where
they are only going to differ marginally
it's an opportunity of course for Bernie
Sanders to say this exposes that my
health care plan is obviously the one
but the problem is every time
he tried to do that Joe Biden simply
said Bernie this isn't about
single-payer or not this isn't about
Medicare for Ola nah this is about we
pass a law saying no co-pays on
treatment period no delays show up if
you're feeling sick don't do the thing
where you walk so anyway it's it's a
it's a debate obviously many of us
believe no this is more about the
systemic problems with our health
insurance system but Bernie's down by
like 40 in most of these states that are
voting on Tuesday it's just not enough
to turn it around and while no crowd
certainly didn't help either candidate
in terms of cheering and momentum by
having no crowd and by having only two
candidates this was the most substantive
debate of any debate that we have had so
far now it would have been more
substance of anyway with two people
right we can't it's not just because
there was no audience but not having an
audience and moderators of being being
sort of pushed into having to babysit in
a sense as a result of that also
certainly made it more substantive so I
want to hear from you who won and more
the most important thing at this point
is does this change in any way what is
likely to happen on Tuesday as I told
you earlier Louisiana has postponed
their primary Georgia has postponed
their primary and I don't have things
framed too well for you there so that
let me know let me see here we have no
that's not the right view either
but we want to get as much on the screen
as possible I am I would love to look at
some of the what you would consider to
be the most relevant clips from this
debate let me see if I just do a hashtag
search for dem debate we should be able
to get some of our some some different
clips and we'll look at some momentarily
if you have any so anyway I want to hear
from you let me know via super chat
what's on your mind let me know via
twitch subscription for example someone
just subscribed with twitch and asked
what's my shoe size and although that is
completely not relevant it's between
nine and ten depending on the brand and
and shoe style I also wear a custom
orthotic because I do have flat feet and
that makes me have to get a half-size
bigger in some things and I know that
that for a lot of voters that is an
issue of paramount importance going into
the Tuesday primaries let me say thanks
to
briggs whose new member number 17
tonight at join pakman.com Richard
Grinnell is new member number 18 tonight
William woods is new member number 19
this evening I want to say thank you to
Vicki cop who is new member number 20
also signing up was kevin de Niccolo who
is new member number 21 on my website
and alexander luna is new member number
22 thanks to all of you for signing up
at join pakman.com I I do very much
appreciate it and love hearing from
everybody and the support from him from
everybody okay a lot of people want me
to talk about Biden dementia listen I
mean if you if you look at the closing
statement of Joe Biden tonight if your
idea is that Bernie Sanders should run
on Joe's demented eye I think you have a
hard time there's no question Joe Biden
has slowed down cognitively from where
he was when he ran circles around Paul
Ryan in the 2008 debate as I'm sorry
with 2000 2012 debate that was oh it was
Palin in 2008 forget about that against
uh Paul Ryan in 2012 there's no question
that he slowed down cognitively as
statistically most people who were
approaching 80 years old have but again
I think Bernie knows running on Joe
Biden dementia doesn't work that's why
when he was asked about it during the
CNN Town Hall last week he declined to
go that route I think everybody knows
it's not it's not a winning it's not a
winning path certainly okay questions
coming in Bethany O'Neill has signed up
heard about it says far-fetched is Biden
Nina Turner the best combination put it
out of your mind it's never happening I
mean it's just not happening
Adam Waddington says I heard the word
momentum all this I hear the word
momentum all the time in relation to
primaries and debates what does that
actually mean often it means nothing the
real point at which I saw momentum make
a difference was after Biden won South
Carolina and then got a bunch of
endorsements from the moderates there
was momentum not yet reflected in the
polls going into Super Tuesday and Biden
indeed had it as evidenced by the fact
that he over performed the poles the
poles which had been done a couple days
prior didn't reflect the addition
that Joe Biden had oftentimes momentum
means nothing Kunal Singh says what are
your thoughts about the social security
vote issue that was the worst mode the
Social Security vote issue was the worst
moment for for Biden in the entire
debate I think and again I I don't
believe it's going to make a difference
in the end
Shaner says didn't expect Biden to be so
combative I wish Bernie didn't follow
suit
two hours arguing the past didn't get us
closer to progressive values yeah you
know there were people saying Bernie's
not being aggressive enough there are
people saying Bernie's being too
combative in the end I think it was just
both candidates trying to match match
each other we do have a hype train
happening over on Twitch darka has
subscribed with prime that's the
username as I see it in 88 fingers
subscribed and says what are your
thoughts on the likes of the latest
article on the intercept Biden Sanders
ticket haven't seen it but I will check
it out Jambo Bren also subscribed with
the message yo yo welcome and yo I'm
glad to have you here
Myles Kaufman says my opinion nobody.one
changes little how do I convince Bernie
supporters Biden is better than Trump
and who is Bernie's successor for the
movement don't know about the successor
listen here's my suggestion as far as
the the Bernie bros and thanks to turkey
bacon and cheese turkey bacon and cheese
has just come in out of nowhere with a
shot across the bow gifting 10 community
subscriptions on Twitch and turkey bacon
remains ladies and gentlemen the top sub
gifter in channel history on on twitch
for us i would actually let the Bernie
supporters who have not yet voted let
them vote don't try to dissuade them
from voting again a primaries are
getting posted postponed
everything's getting shut down we've
decentralized production of the David
Pakman show starting tomorrow I will be
producing from home it screw you if you
had any idea what's gone on over the
last 72 hours your hair would look like
mine sometimes does let me put it that
way
I don't know how that's going to affect
turnout but we should not dissuade
anyone from voting how they are going to
vote how they wanted to vote all along
we don't want anyone disenfranchised
like that once it's over then we have to
make the case that listen we're to the
left of Joe Biden but we are much
further to the left of Donald Trump and
I don't want Trump replacing Ruth Bader
Ginsburg
so that then my kids and possibly
grandkids imagine that these people
don't even exist yet these people aren't
even an idea yet are affected by the
fact that we reelect the Donald Trump I
can't morally participate in anything
that would help Trump get reelected so
I'm gonna vote for Biden okay there it
is but let's let's wait let's let's let
you know let everybody vote for sure
Biden won because no implode also Dow
futures yeah I don't know what Dow
futures are looking like let's see Dow
futures I think investing.com has let's
see where is that investing calm Dow 30
futures down a thousand very good down
about four-and-a-half percent and yeah
so we're expecting listen states are
shutting down
I am expecting it to get much worse and
I am even putting on the table Oh is
something wrong with my mic people are
saying there is something wrong with my
microphone I don't want that it looks
fine on my end let me just make sure
everything's plugged properly here Mike
is right okay good
listen I would not be shocked if we see
a 30% decline in the market before we
hit bottom or even 3540 percent but I
hope it doesn't happen
my strategy is unchanged on the 1st and
the 15th of the month more like the
third and the 17th of the month I just
accumulate more index funds and keep
grabbing dividends and you know that's
my time horizon right but I think it's
it's going to get very very ugly very
very very ugly Kalyan Brooks says do you
think Bernie's active reading keeps him
sharp unlike Trump and a lot of other
politicians around his age yes I mean I
don't know much about Bernie's reading
program but I think that that's that's
probably that's certainly a great thing
if for for cognitive abilities for sure
let me thank so many people on Twitch
for participating in the hype train
athenian knights legendary dog liam ha
mama says david do you think bernie
should have referred to specific facts
and figures
when debating medicare-for-all in
climate change yes I mean it can't hurt
rcj Pisani says shout out to granny
smith apples the best Apple out there
ladies and gentlemen is the Granny Smith
and I very much appreciate that and we
are we we have four minutes to achieve
that level five hypetrain if you're on
YouTube but this is a big distraction
and I completely apologize to you for it
okay we are taking super chats
addressing who do you think won but do
you think it'll make a difference that
is the question let's look at a couple
of clips from this debate let's see what
we've got here sorry hold on I'm sorry
you get rid of the nine super PACs you
have Knights of I don't have inside you
mommy listen oh yeah you go ahead let's
go come on give me a break don't okay
that was a pretty funny moment let's
let's see this one oh here is the social
this is Biden's worst part okay overall
I think it's not gonna make a huge
difference but this was the absolute
worst part in my view of for Joe Biden
you just be straight with the American
people I am saying that you have been on
the floor of the Senate time and time
again talking about the need to cut
Social Security Medicare and veterans
programs is that true no it's not true
what that is not true that is not true
what is true is I when I argued that we
should freeze federal spending I spent
Social Security as well I meant Medicare
Medicaid
I'm not veterans man I met every single
solitary thing in the government and I
not only tried it once I tried it twice
I tried it third time and I tried it a
fourth time were so where it's gonna get
difficult is it's it's 2% more complex
than Joe Biden said cut it right because
Joe Biden said freeze it if you freeze
Social Security
meaning you don't adjust benefits for
inflation if you have 2% inflation in
buying power it's a two percent cut Joe
Biden can hide behind saying I was
saying freeze it I didn't say cut
it and then it's a fight right anyone
who wants to think critically would say
it's a de facto cut it is you when you
say don't in don't match inflation
you're saying at the end of the day the
purchasing power goes down because
inflation has gone up Joe Biden can hide
behind it and say I'm just talking about
a freeze you know that's it let's see a
little more of this claw time for
whatever reason talking about the need
to cut Social Security and Medicare and
veterans programs no I did not Medicare
need to cut any of those programs
senator we have a deficit we have Social
Security and Medicare looming the number
of people on Susskind Medicare is now 40
million people it's gonna be 80 million
in 15 years
would you consider looking at those
programs age of eligibility the cost of
living put it on the table yes sir is
absolute you have to Social Security is
not the hard one to solve Medicare that
is the gorilla in the room and again put
Joe Biden can hide behind
I didn't say cut it I said put it on the
table do we extend retirement age so
listen we we all know that when Biden
said it he would have considered any
number of these different things but
when when we when it becomes a fight and
you've got to overcome a 50 point
deficit in Florida for Bernie Sanders I
just don't know that what happened
tonight what that would happen tonight
is enough let's see if we have any other
clips that are of interest we did the
social security social security we did
the super PAC thing we did okay here is
a supercut of Joba remember the right
and some Bernie supporters are doing the
dementia stuff this is the supercut of
all the things that Biden did that
proved he has dementia as per some we
can do that we did that we've been
through this before with the coronavirus
we've been through this before me
Scoobies we've been through this before
with dealing with the viruses that the
n1 h15 as well as what happened in
Africa we can do that we did that we've
been through this before with the Quran
okay all right I mean listen if that's
what you got again
Bernie Bernie knows that dementia Joe is
a losing argument for him and that's why
he's staying away from it that that's
why staying away from it okay let me do
a couple of other thank-yous and then
we're going to continue
Billy Albers is new member number 23
tonight at join pakman.com oh that's it
I thought I had more people to thank but
I don't that's sad okay Billy Albers
thank you
grab a subscription at join pakman.com
and if you're just joining us on YouTube
I do have a very small favor to ask and
the favor is simply like the stream and
hit subscribe we somehow have 3,300
people here but only 300 likes which is
it's ugly it reflects poorly on me it
reflects poorly on my staff and and all
of that stuff so no in all seriousness
please do make sure you you like and
subscribe when you come in it does help
us okay continuing with super chats
brick nose says stanislaus bolongo I'm
sorry no brick nose said nothing
Stanislas bolongo said and I'm sorry it
just scrolled past me pooh pooh [ __ ]
pepe laughs I'm not sure what language
that is daya Brabham said disgusted
current Fulbright stuck in UK afraid to
come back without Medicare for all I
would rather be away from family than in
the states should I stay or go I could I
am NOT I don't know everything about
your life I couldn't possibly advise you
brick no says sadly I think Biden won he
sounded confident didn't mess up this
was a pitch for electability Bernie
didn't make it
Billy Albers mega guillotine for
president 22 2020 Mads hey David shout
about shout about from the beam Fox
gotta go Oh
borrow what table honest Wow I've been
seeing a lot of Trump supporters here in
Missouri saying they went and voted
Biden to stop Bernie access to those
trying to teach the DNC a lesson by not
voting for Biden understand that the
establishment doesn't learn lessons vote
liberal socialist says 2024 will be fun
ramani de vide doe says David you're
beautiful please take care of yourself
you deserve it also could kovat 19 help
Bernie as less older people will be
voting aye yeah yeah I know that's that
there was an idea about that last week
it didn't didn't work I don't know that
it'll do much
Devon black says are you
planning on addressing the results of
the exit polls seems to highly suggest
election fraud or fraud as I say we will
be looking at that this week
JC sends a dollar erin gates says bernie
voters will protest vote for trump or
just stay home Biden has too much
history for a true progressive to
support him learn your lesson from 2016
Biden equals Trump reelected well
certainly you know we hear a lot of
people talking about self-fulfilling
prophecies that certainly would be one
for sure a Jane womanpower says late
arrival like and subscribe beautiful
viewers yes listen to Jane like and
subscribe always important damien Garvey
says how do more delegates help Bernie
can he in any way significantly
influenced by Daan's campaign with them
uh listen it's all he's got it's all
he's got so the alternative is he drops
out and I'm starting to see the the
betting numbers are increasingly going
in the direction of Bernie's out by
Wednesday the betting numbers that the
money the money says that and we will we
will have to wait and see let me say
thank you and welcome to Orion cosa who
is new member number twenty-four tonight
at join pakman.com Thank You Orion I
appreciate that I played a played soccer
when I was a new immigrant here in the
United States with an Orion and I
haven't seen him in 25 years
but that reminded me of him let's see
here
purp dolo says why have you not shown
anywhere near the support for Bernie
that the other progressive podcast
YouTube channels have throughout the
primary process oh come on guys come on
juni McGraw Biden is worrying me he
rambles platitudes lies or misleads on
issues and there were times where I had
no idea what the hell he was talking
about China poverty improvements are
akin to Jack the Ripper WTF yeah so
here's the thing when Biden started
let's see if we can even find that damn
debate let's see Castro let's see if we
can find that section
oh it's finding stuff about who Leon
Castro maybe we can find it if I
searched Cuba
[Music]
no that's from an old debate yeah I'm
not finding it so I interestingly enough
I thought that Biden did not handle the
entire Castro part well but the crazy
thing is for example Florida votes
Tuesday
Bernie's losing by 45 the idea that
Florida Democrats are going to switch
from Biden to Bernie even if he insists
listen its authoritarian but the reading
program is good it's like it's an
impossible position for Bernie because
he needs to try to get people to switch
from Biden to him he seems to have a
ceiling of about 38 nationally he needs
Florida Democrats to vote for him and he
again has to I mean what else can he say
right I mean it's it's the truth
just because China reduced poverty
doesn't mean we like China's government
just because Cuba had a reading program
doesn't mean we like the fact that Fidel
Castro said in the 50s he was gonna call
for elections and he never did but it's
it's impossible and he's just not gonna
turn any any voters around with that it
was very very difficult but BVM BVM says
can't like like folder is mostly erotic
fiction okay that that's um that's more
information than I needed Kunal Singh
says how do you predict the debate
between Biden versus Trump it listen it
could go either way it could be an
absolute crushing by Donald Trump
depending on what happens with
coronavirus quite frankly it could be a
very difficult situation for Donald
Trump I don't know I don't know what to
expect but it's it's gonna be
interesting the george says when folks
say progressives stay home it sounds
like a threat to give us trump if they
don't get their way we all need to vote
against Trump in November I wish
everybody felt that way
MADD says I meant to say shoutout from
the bean love the show vote blue no
matter who also there needs to be more
progressive politicians yes oh so here
in the bean I just call it Boston we do
have news and it is about to get very
very ugly necessarily ugly here okay
Ohio Governor Mike DeWine says bars and
restaurants can stay open for Kerry
in delivery but what we can't have is
people congregated and seating in
California Governor Gavin Newsom ordered
all bars wineries brew pubs and night
closed clubs to close and asked everyone
over 65 to self isolate Illinois shut
down bars and restaurants through March
30th Massachusetts governor Charlie
Baker ordered all bars and restaurants
to close starting Tuesday March 17th I
guess we've got to have a good time
tomorrow and remain closed for a month
that's a joke by the way this is this is
the right thing and Charlie Baker by and
large as a Republican governor listen I
get it that it we in Massachusetts we
both have here we have a cluster we have
a cluster it started with the Biogen
conference there's a lot of horrible
things going on
at the same time we do have significant
medical infrastructure some of the best
hospitals in the country are here Mass
General Boston Children's Brigham and
Women's and overall given all of that
Charlie Baker has been has been handling
this relatively well if anything he
could have acted even sooner
Pennsylvania Governor Tom wolf ordered
all restaurants and bars across five
counties to close dine in facilities to
help control the spread of the virus
really important guys if you are in
Boston the this is very important if you
are going to be unsure where to get
corned beef or pastrami Michaels deli in
Brookline is starting a limited delivery
program issue of foremost importance
they will deliver knishes I was I made
sure to stock up on both potato and
spinach yesterday they will deliver
corned beef day they will deliver
pastrami make sure to tell Steve at
Michael's deli that I that I sent you
well I I checked in yesterday there
picked up a bunch of stuff to stock up
and listen and it's not just I'm kidding
about Michaels deli although I'm not the
knishes are extraordinary but this is
going to be very tough for a lot of
small businesses and the this is sadly
likely only the beginning this is likely
only the beginning okay
other super chats coming in Oh No let me
thank some folks first Rick Dryden is
new member number 25 tonight thank you
Rick I appreciate that I also want to
say thanks to
Gregory carpenter whose new member
number 26 tonight at join pakman.com all
of these streams and you know our
ability to totally decentralize
production for the coming weeks to not
spread kovat 19 and the equipment
requirements and all of that stuff it's
made possible by people who grab
memberships at join pakman.com so please
do consider doing it we're gonna be
streaming a Tuesday election results and
on and on and on you can use that coupon
code above my head 2020 now for a for a
discount let me say thanks to Deadwood
605 for the twitch subscription AC has
handed out another community
subscription and I very much appreciate
that okay Santa Claus anything you want
for Christmas I can hook it fat I'm
Jewish so now no Christmas gifts thank
you Roswell Satterwhite says a lot of
progressives made the case that Biden
couldn't stand on a debate stage for two
hours one-on-one without melting down
that was untrue tonight yeah listen I
mean I haven't really been talking about
this too much I said last week okay
let's let's go to the beginning the the
Biden dimension narrative has been
pushed by Bernie ER Buster's and
trumpets in in fact it was crazy on
Twitter last week you had trumpets
sharing videos made by Bernie ER
Buster's about Biden dementia you had
Bernie ER Buster's sharing trumpets
videos about Biden dementia Bernie knew
that this was not a good strategy
so when during the Town Hall last week
Bernie was asked about Biden saying
weird things that dementia cognitive
Bernie didn't take the bait to three
times during the town hall last week
they tried to goad Bernie into the Biden
dementia stuff and Biden didn't do it
and the expectations were set where
people were expecting that Biden wasn't
going to be able to put together a
sentence during the debate tonight and
of course it didn't happen and you know
Biden forgot the name of Ebola and and
whatever but the expectation had been
set so low that listen it's in the end I
feel like the tonight's debate will not
move
things one way or the other more than
two points and that's just not going to
be enough Tam I am in my honest opinion
establishment Dems won't learn a lesson
if they can count on us to vote blue no
matter who we have to show them that we
won't vote for them fine do it
do it Trump will win and then in four
years you you know pick up the pieces
and nominate someone else that's not
what I'm going to do to be clear I'm
just I'm not gonna argue with people
right oh all I can do is give you my
perspective I don't want Trump replacing
RBG Biden says he supports the green new
deal on his website Trump doesn't a
Biden would get us back into climate
prayers climate from won't Biden's tax
plan is better than Trump's I know it
sucks right it's milquetoast it's
incremental ISM a lot of people don't
like it but I'm not gonna do anything
that might get Trump reelected I will
you can't count on me for that who would
win in a wrestling match corn pop vs.
Jim Jordan you know I don't even know
who corn pop is I still have no clue who
corn pop is okay we had a whole bunch of
these come in so let's see okay Matt
Chavez Bernie supporter here saying vote
blue no matter who okay that's
responsible RJ elite hi Dave had been
watching since 2015 you partially
partially inspired me to get a degree in
politics which is hilarious because I
don't have a degree in politics
graduating soon thank you I love that
thank you brick no says Bernie missed a
chance on Cuba should have made a
parallel to Biden's kind words towards
KKK leaders while not supporting the KKK
itself might have been better might have
been better cheapy Roman says the
Kardashians are lying to you I don't
even know what they're saying
Mateus Veloso poopoo [ __ ] browned out
in this debate
Pepe laughs I don't is that French I
don't know what language that person
speaking serial famine says Biden and
Dick Lugar great name for an appendage
that's not bad
the real life Channel what happens if
the primaries are canceled on Tuesday
will it help Bernie for the delay you
know I think that the Tuesday primaries
have more or less been agreed up upon
just good just doing it and I wouldn't
be shocked if right after you see a
bunch of those states
buckled down significantly fork ovid 19
I wouldn't wouldn't be surprised at all
if you're just joining us we are doing
post show post debate analysis I would
love to hear from you who won the debate
and does it make a difference for
tuesday's for primaries Arizona Ohio
Florida I say Florida and Arizona
Florida Ohio Illinois I believe are are
the four if you're joining us on Twitch
make sure to follow
we're just 200 followers away from
30,000 which is a major accomplishment
it would be a major accomplishment for
us if you're joining me on youtube
please like and subscribe there's nearly
3500 people watching but only a thousand
likes and the likes the likes are a
beautiful thing we've been looking at
likes very strongly and they're working
well for us so please please do like and
subscribe it really does make a
difference we joke around but it's it's
a big thing Joanna Roy or Rua the French
word for king of course in light of
Biden suggesting a possible Republican
running mate what confidence do you have
that the Biden scj pick would be any
better than Trump listen Biden said he
would be open to a Republican running
mate hypothetically Biden's not choosing
a Republican running mate Biden would
replace RBG with someone far better than
Trump would these we've all got to relax
with some of this stuff
Jen Jen says can't do monthly I don't
know what that means love what you do
I'm up in Franklin County keep up the
good work
oh I see you're sending five bucks
instead of getting a subscription
Franklin County I was just in Franklin
County I was in this is before any
banned quarantines I'm talking weeks ago
okay I went to hope and olive delightful
restaurant in Greenfield Massachusetts
and there's this cool little bar called
Seymour also in downtown greenfield
which I like I was out there not not
long ago okay BVM BVM asks how many
tomatoes could you steal using your but
if they're any larger than cherry
probably none Miguel Palacio says hey
David so have you officially endorsed by
Dhin listened
isn't about endorsements this is about
it's down to Bernie and Biden I believe
the mathematical path is for Biden I
will vote for either Biden or Bernie
against Trump
this isn't blue no matter who you give
me a disastrous Republic a disastrous
Democrat and a great Republican I'll
vote for the Republican what do I care
but of the two Democrats left I I will
vote for whichever is the nominee it
doesn't require an endorsement
Dandy's OG says don't worry kovat 19
will stop the boomers from voting for
liar dementia Biden Bernie 2020 you're
living in a fantasy world my friend and
a counterproductive self-destructive one
at that plasmon says I'm a liberal and
support nuclear power it's the solution
to climate change liquid metal reactors
are immune to meltdowns as a property of
physics listen I've said I am open to
new nuclear as a bridge if it is
predefined that we are eventually going
to renewables a period that that's
that's what I've said all right let me
say a few thank-yous over on Twitch
quakes says Biden did better than I
thought Omni Liberals rise up okay and
okay that's it on Twitch let me say some
membership thank-yous
oh no there I sorry I don't have any we
do have a goal of 50 new members tonight
we're halfway there and I invite you
grab a membership at join pakman.com
it's quick it's easy and it feels good
that I can assure you okay other super
chats Ryan Wilson says the cool virus
test is reverse transcriptase polymerase
chain reaction
I learned that procedure in community
college it is not technically
challenging a powerful person wants to
suppress the stats shoutout to molecular
biology students yeah I mean listen guys
we we have to recognize that the oh this
is interesting
our website showed incorrect data due to
a malicious act world ah meters is
getting hacked that's crazy this website
they've been covering everything that
that's been going on
if you look at these numbers and you
believe for a second that the US has
only 3700 cases you're living in a
fantasy world as testing is expanding we
are getting very high numbers of new
cases per day we're you know for all
this time Trump was saying no new cases
do we had over 800 today already I read
one estimate that says we might have
more than half a million cases
nationally already now a really
important thing about the tests okay the
test we have there's a couple there's
there's probably more than two but I am
aware of two ways that you can test for
someone who has or has had a virus right
the test we have right now doesn't test
for antibodies so if you have koban 19
and you recover naturally you have
antibodies but in the same way as if you
were vaccinated but we don't have an
antibody test right now the test right
now is testing for the pathogen
eventually if if it is true that there
are thousands tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of people who are
asymptomatic are almost completely
asymptomatic you have a dry cough for a
week and that's it but you had the virus
eventually in order to figure out how
widespread it has been we are going to
need to get an antibody test and sample
large populations not people who are
sick okay if we do that and we find out
holy-shit
15% of the population 20% of the
population has already had corona virus
that is going to be extremely important
to figuring out what the path forward is
tomorrow we are going to be doing a deep
dive into vaccines antivirals and
antibody of treatments possibilities
that are being developed right now and
you know we'll be covering it all week
so I won't get fully into it now but the
long and short of it is you can only
hold down this number for so long we are
rapidly increasing the number of cases
the u.s. is now one two three four five
six seven eighth in the world in terms
of cases that are known again we might
have half a million cases according to
some experts the idea that
Trump is doing well because the case
number is low will very quickly
evaporate and then we are really going
to have to be looking at what is the
death rate are we slowing down
transmission and so far if we look at
USA numbers as you can see this is not
what you want to do at some point you
need to get to an inflection point where
this number starts going down it's more
every day and rapidly increasing if you
look at South Korea for example you see
that they reached that inflection point
between February 29th and March 3rd and
it has been on the decline since people
are gonna need to stop being idiots and
they're gonna need to stay home if you
look at Italy they are they are still
struggling and they have not hit the
inflection point it looked like maybe
they had hit it from the 12th to the
13th but no they have not anyway you
guys understand math and data a China
hit that inflection point as well as you
can see they hit it right around
February 12th 13th and it's been on the
decline and one important thing is going
to be active cases as you can see China
is now second in active cases they were
first for the majority of this thing and
eventually China is going to drop below
Iran for active cases they're shedding
about a thousand active cases a day and
if you look at cases per population the
situation in Italy is tragic if you look
in Switzerland Switzerland is actually
second in the world and Katyn known
cases per population the death rate is
is very very low below 1% right now of
course the idea is if on average it
takes 17 days for someone the average
person who dies to die after contracting
symptoms it may just be early for
Switzerland but that this is it's going
to get very very ugly people are gonna
need to behave because it's it's gonna
be I don't want to be part of the
problem and we are doing everything we
can I'm doing everything I can
personally and at the show we are also
doing everything we can we've
decentralized production starting to
produce everybody's gonna be working
from home tomorrow
should not result in any interruption in
programming for you new member number 27
tonight is Robert Braun thanks Robert
for signing up at join pakman.com Tina
valdon also grabbed a membership at join
pakman.com I want to say thank you to
Jesse wess to Jesse your new member
number 29 tonight at join pakman.com I I
so appreciate it really appreciate your
support and if you like what we do
consider getting a membership that's all
I'm saying
okay other super chats sorry that was a
pretty big tangent but we're gonna do
other super chats Shana's says Arizona
voters so far announced school closures
will not affect vote centers using
school buildings important information
Kowalski from Nebraska says sorry there
it is thanks for sharing my link earlier
have some money
thanks Kowalski John will accessor our
new fan here whose blue no matter who
progressive rocker says China's okay for
sending them our manufacturing our jobs
and our money including Bloomberg the
person Biden wants to appoint he loves
China
Andres says vote blue no matter who
gives away any incentive for the DNC and
their candidate to pay any attention to
your issues thus revokes all of your
power
Damien Garvey says in light of the low
progressive turnout do you think the
Democratic Party is that interest in
appealing to the progressive voter well
they're going to need the progressive
voters if they want to defeat Trump
because it's likely to come down to just
a few states so the DNC would be stupid
to ignore the progressive voter ranch
elder says I've been hoarding elements
of medical hashtag Doomer yeah let's
look at elements of medical actually I
think I tweeted that yesterday by the
way you should really be following me on
Twitter let's see elements of medical
it's unclear if Donald Trump found them
yet I think I tweeted it last night
where is that here it is yeah a lot of
elements that frankly we wouldn't be
ordering unless it was something like
this but we're ordering a lot of
different elements of medical we are
working on cures apparently apparently
elements of medical meant coronavirus
itself that's what was ordered
and served up on a platter and whoever
Trump ordered it from seems to have come
through because we've got a whole hell
of a lot of it Billie Albers says Miege
guillotine for pres 2020 okay
COO nice thing says what are your
thoughts on altered carbon season 2 you
know I've only watched the first episode
so far and I don't know I mean see you
know it's Joel can't buy I've read the
book fifteen years ago or whenever it
was written one of my favorite books of
the genre season one was so good with
Martha hey Greta and Joel Kinnaman I
don't know if Martha is in season two I
heard a rumor that she was and as far as
I know no Joel Kinnaman people are
saying it starts slow but gets better
I'm gonna watch it all but I've been
watching hunters on Amazon Prime this is
one of the best programs that I have
seen period the hunters is extraordinary
Al Pacino is in it playing a Nazi hunter
fantastic actors the one of the guys
from the Americans is in it I forget his
name it's fantastic it's like a mix of a
Quentin Tarantino style with something
else it's just fantastic you've got to
see hunters with Al Pacino on Amazon and
you'll have time to do it as this the
country is slowly shutting down Terry
says if think EO sorry scrolled if
thinking of sitting out 2020 election
please read New York Times regarding the
Trump administration's overhaul of
federal courts think of immigrant
friends and colleagues very important
race the turtle says roommates and I are
sick here in SoCal the hack on rural
domitor was crazy saying the Vatican had
300,000 new cases what that's crazy John
will excessed to clarify I'm only boat
bien MW to beat Trump Bloo no matter who
beat to beat Trump as we must yes of
course Captain Crunch says David let's
keep it real Biden should have made an
effort to go left but he stood his
ground and proved he's a corporate shill
how are progressives gonna vote for this
guy it's immoral I mean listen morality
is clearly in the eye of the beholder
because for me it's immoral to do
anything in November that helps Trump
win that's immoral to me so I'm not
gonna do it I just can't I can't
do it my friends let me welcome Valerie
Frank who is new member number 30
tonight our goal is 50 Valerie is new
member number 30 this evening very much
appreciate that if you're just joining
us on YouTube we are analyzing the
aftermath of the Bernie Biden debate
make sure to LIKE the stream and hit
subscribe where are we by the way on
YouTube subscribers I just haven't
looked for a while we are at 812
thousand for 24 okay so so yes please do
remember like and subscribe really helps
us out a John Iren bark says Bart Bernie
won debate Biden wins nomination if we
all roll over to the DNC then we will
never have a voice maybe we need a Nero
and his fiddle Jonathan Brown is now a
SOI boy Quinton Coleman has signed up at
the SOI boy level Marika says zero
deaths in Finland so far my ex had
corona for two weeks after a trip to
Austria now getting better glad to hear
that Jane womanpower says won't let me
send my happy vibes to like and
subscribe
sad faith face sixth attempt let's see a
lot going on there Jane thank you a Tom
step says Bernie came off today fighting
for policy I think he's running to push
Biden to adopt some progressive policies
rather than to win outright in my
opinion I think a lot of Bernie's Bernie
or Buster's will reject that analysis
Josef van Scoy says did you notice that
Biden said that his SCOTUS nomination
will be a black woman that Kamala Harris
trade her endorsement for a seat at the
SCOTUS yeah I mean there's probably more
than just Kamala Harris the real life
channel since we need to stop the virus
from spreading do you think people
should show up on Tuesday primaries the
virus is spreading fast and can be on
the voting machines is it smart for
people to show up you know what you are
making a very good point I am not even
going to speculate I'm going to leave
that up to the health professionals
because that's too serious of a thing
we're talking about enfranchisement and
voting and not spreading a virus I don't
know what the right answer is I'm not
even going
to speculate the Beckman Nader says with
a $50 Super chap $50 Canadian I don't
know how much that is right now it's
either like 55 us or 45 u.s. right I
don't know says two questions for you
David as a Canadian I want to know why
American politicians and the media not
the people are so against single-payer
health care systems do you think Biden
will put Bernie somewhere in his
administration
I don't think Biden would put Bernie in
his administration and oh you know not
there is widespread support within some
elements I sound like Trump now elements
of Medical within certain elements of
media there is increasingly openness to
Medicare for all but it is not popular
with the establishment that's for sure
luck Bach says could China be lying
about the amount of new cases I know why
you would think that
however w-h-o inspectors say that
China's being honest now and they've
really cut the number of cases
dramatically it kehna
a Jerrica new set econo says hey from
Scotland thoughts on UK Korona response
I mean it's better than the US I know a
lot of our UK viewers are saying that it
is the response in the UK has not been
good we have a pretty low bar here in
the US and I think it's been better now
this idea of we just need to get herd
immunity gets 60 people and 60% of the
people infected I don't know who said
that
I'm gonna research it for tomorrow and I
would want to know a little bit about
the efficacy of that and the ethics
quite frankly plasma and says renewables
are expensive the energy is free but the
upkeep and maintenance of infrastructure
isn't look up cost in Germany versus
France okay I have and that's not the
perspective I came away with Andrew born
yes born David I appreciate your message
and your brutal honesty no matter the
cost real quick did you check out
Netflix dirty money episode on Jared
Kushner no I saw a bunch of the dirty
money episodes in season one it became a
little tedious so I've not yet jumped
into season 2 I've been watching Rotten
which is a very good show I'm watching I
saw a great episode about sugar cane and
now watching an episode about chocolate
and I have not seen the Jared Kushner
episode quite yet but I've heard that it
is compelling stuff let me say thank you
Sarah Toa for a two-month Prime
subscription on Twitch Simon 21b has
subscribed with prime and says hi thank
you very much I appreciate that okay
let's look at a couple other dem debate
clips here um let's see
catch up on the highlights yeah let's
see what we've got here but nowhere near
enough I mean you mentioned we started
this debate talking about a war like
situation in terms of the corona virus
and we said we have to act accordingly
you said it I think you're right I said
it we have to act
dramatically boldly if we're gonna save
lives in this country and around the
world
I look at climate change in exactly the
same way it's not a question of
re-entering the Paris of course that's
fine
who cares it's not a big deal the deal
right now is do we have the courage and
this gets back to the point I'm trying
to make all night long do we take on the
healthcare industry and tell them their
profits are not more important than
health care for all do we take on the
fossil fuel industry well so listen I
thought this was interesting because
this is one of those things where of
course Bernie's right Bernie's
completely right and and there's there's
no question that Bernie proved his
progressive credentials in contrast to
Joe Biden here but the thing I couldn't
get away from is Bernie's been saying
the exact same thing for a long time and
a lot of people say that's good Bernie's
consistent and that's absolutely right
there's no question Biden has not
compromised I'm sorry Bernie has not
compromised
in terms of his values and what he sees
but the language and the stump speech
have been identical essentially for five
years right since since Bernie ran
starting in 2015-2016 whenever it was he
needs to somehow turn around an almost
insurmountable deficit to Joe Biden
right now it's just not it's a math
thing right you keep doing the same
thing and you're down by a crazy amount
right now to Joe Biden this is the last
chance coming in and
saying the same stuff I don't know that
is going to change anything around that
was what I was thinking of course
Bernie's right but he got himself into a
thirty forty point deficit in states
that are voting on Tuesday with this
exact same stuff he needed to do
something different and I don't know
that he did even though he was of course
completely correct in terms of the
fossil fuel industry these guys have
been lying they've been lying for years
like the tobacco industry lied fifty
years ago oh we don't know if if fossil
fuels if oil and carbon emissions are
causing climate change they knew Exxon
Mobil knew they lied in fact I think
they should be held criminally
accountable but this Jake is an issue of
enormous consequence what Joe is saying
goes nowhere near enough it's not a
question of money let me give me a
minute yeah let's we have time to talk
about this this is a world-shaking event
I understand I just want to give him a
chance to respond that we can collect
let's stay on we're staying on this
issue number one
no more subsidies for fossil fuel
industry no more drilling on federal
lands no more drilling including
offshore no ability for the oil industry
to continue to drill period ends number
one number two we're in a situation as
well where we cannot we are able to move
rapidly to change the dynamic in terms
of what we can do to set in motion in
fact that he says climate change Paris
the court doesn't mean much we could get
everything exactly right we're 15
percent of the problem 85 percent of the
problem is over there we need someone
who can deal internationally we need
someone who can bring the world together
again we need someone who can move in a
direction that in fact if you violate
the commitment you make you will pay a
economic price for it like what's
happening in China they're they're
exporting coal significant cold thank
you look obviously the Paris Accord is
is useful but it doesn't go any wind
if you laughter Joe then you're missing
the point your this is an existential
crisis bingo who are you you talk about
you know I'm talking about stopping
fracking as soon as we possibly can I'm
talking about telling the fuss this was
the moment where I thought that were
this was actually the moment where I
realized the debate wouldn't change any
which was when Bernie started getting
into more agitated Bernie which I like
personally right and Biden's took this
position and looked calm this was the
moment where I realized you know this
this is not going to help Bernie make up
a 40 point deficit in Florida a 20-point
deficit in Illinois etc this was really
the moment where I realized that I'm
curious to see what other people think
and of course everything Bernie saying
is right but that's when I came to the
realization at this point in time bull
industry that they are gonna stop
destroying this planet no ifs buts and
maybes about it I'm talking about solar
to try well I'm not sure your proposal
doesn't I'm talking about speaking to
China and again that's an opportunity
where Bernie says well you know but
Biden says I'm talking about the same
thing you're talking about Bernie Bernie
says well I'm not sure your proposal
does that it's it's with the language is
too weak you're not gonna change votes
and again remember if we were just
starting and we didn't know who was
winning at this point okay
Bernie has the potential to get crushed
on Tuesday it's possible that Biden will
be winning by by two million votes after
the Tuesday balazar cast this was not
going to turn it around and this was the
point where I noticed that the countries
all over the world and in this moment
making the point that instead of
spending 1.8 trillion on weapons of
destruction designed to kill each other
maybe we should pool our resources and
fight our common enemy which is climate
change I know your heart is in the right
place but this requires dramatic bold
action we've got to take on the fossil
fuel industry your plan does not do that
my plan takes down the fossil for the
industry and it unites the world you
just got really sane what's he gonna do
he's gonna bring these countries
together make it clear to them I'm
saying we bring them together make them
live up to the commitments if they don't
live up to the commitments they pay a
financial price for it they pay an
economic price for it because we can do
everything my city my state is three
feet above sea level I don't need a
lecture on what's gonna happen about
rising seas I know what happens I
watched the whole dumb war
Peninsula just like it is in South
Carolina an arrest something I know a
little bit about I wrote the first
climate change bill that was in the
Congress was PolitiFact's that was a
game-changer I'm the guy who came along
and said with Dick Lugar that we're
gonna trade we'll forgive your debt if
you don't cut down your forest I've been
way ahead of this curve this idea that
all of a sudden
Bernie found this out is amazing to me
senator Sanders Bernie didn't find that
out bernie is listening to the
scientists and what you know you're
talking about making countries around
the world fulfill their commitments
those commitments are not enough anyway
all right I think we're almost at the
end I think you guys get how you know
it's it's all muddled enough that it
doesn't change anything
it doesn't change anything guys that
that's the reality and you know I'm open
to to being proven wrong on Tuesday of
course let me say thank you to a Jesse
Eaton Jesse Eaton is new member number
31 tonight and Carly Hahn is new member
number 32 tonight really appreciate your
support
I invite you if you're just joining us
our primary source of funding is people
who just grab a membership at join
pakman.com coupon code is up there every
time you sign up this blue bar fills up
and people just get super excited every
time it happens so we're getting there
we're very much getting there okay
other super chats that are coming in
umm-hmm says how do you feel about the
new restrictions in massachusetts I mean
listen it sucks but it's got to happen
we've got to turn the curve around it
just what can we do I'm gonna I'm gonna
abide by whatever is put in place Jane
womanpower says lol 7th try ago so sub
and love like means love yes exactly
Jonathan Brown says David do you think
that it's far off to speculate that
Biden would tap Warren as his VP given
both his shout out to her tonight and
his commitment to choose a female
running mate you know a week ago I would
have said there's no chance in hell that
Biden picks Warren I thought that Biden
was going in the direction of Amy
Klobuchar or Kamala Harris after tonight
I think that there's a chance that Biden
could go towards Warren although again
Warren didn't endorse him but it may
have been that she agreed
to endorse Bernie like that might have
been the deal she doesn't endorse Bernie
and maybe Biden considers her I don't
know not not sure Grace Lee says I have
a friend who genuinely thinks the Dems
paid China to invent the virus in order
to get Trump out of office I hope that
they're in treatment I hope that they're
in treatment
Christopher hatch says Allen combs rest
in peace 1952 to 2017 yeah Alan Colmes
left-wing radio host he was a friend of
mine Alan I have an Alan Colmes story
which was when I was starting to come up
in talker because remember my show
before we had a large youtube channel we
had a radio syndication which we still
have my radio shows on a hundred
stations or more and Alan Colmes reached
out to me and he said I've been watching
your stuff said something complimentary
and said if you're ever in New York
let's get together and when it started
looking like I was going to be moving to
New York City I said I'm gonna be in
town looking at apartments I would love
to get together alan combs said let's
meet up let's get a coffee
he bought me breakfast he talked with me
about radio and behind the scenes at Fox
News and all sorts of different stuff
this was already after the Hannity and
Colmes days and he said I want to learn
more about what you do and it was
amazing because you know a lot of people
in Alan's Co Alan Colmes position where
you know he has a cush cushy this is a
real story for people asking this is not
made up a lot of people who have these
cushy radio gigs and they can just ride
it out to retirement and they don't
really have to innovate in any way it's
very easy for them to see anything that
younger people are doing that's on other
platforms like YouTube and podcasts as
stupid not worth it whatever he actually
saw that it was the wave of the future
and he wanted to learn from me and I'm
not not in a patronizing way he said can
I go check out your studio and see how
you're producing everything and he came
and visited me and brought his tech
person and so on and so forth
excellent guy very tragic that Alan
Colmes passed away in 2017 and he is
still missed he is still missed I
remember driving around when I shortly
after getting my license when I was 16
17 years old and listening to Alan combs
on the radio on WH MP out in out in
western mass very good guy cheeseburgers
747 as a drastic turn around just sends
a very strange looking at a dollar sign
eyeball smiley face okay
Bethany O'Neill says have you watched a
hundred humans on Netflix it's
informative and entertaining gren great
insights into aspects of humanity the
bias episode is great no it popped up as
a recommendation today I didn't know
what it was but I will check it out
marika says do you think the end
justifies the means when it comes to
beating Trump well yeah I mean I do I do
I do believe some we I guess if you're
saying how important is it to make sure
Trump doesn't get more Supreme Court
picks that's a that's an end and I think
it is justified for sure plasmon 19 says
france's electricity is cheaper than
Germany's with Germany relying more on
fossil fuels and renewables nuclear
equals a cheap electric bill okay
cassiano battaglia says although I am
NOT very optimistic about Bernie right
now still love your work and your
coverage man keep up with the great work
thank you I appreciate that if you're
just joining us it has been a very
interesting evening of debate my overall
assessment is essentially some summed up
on my latest tweet which I invite you to
respond to retweet like whatever I'm
deep Ackman on Twitter and I said the
contrast is unmistakable Bernie Sanders
is solidly to Joe Biden's left I also
cannot imagine that tonight's debate
changes the polling in Tuesday's
primaries where am I wrong feel free to
let me know what you think on Twitter or
elsewhere after the stream I will be
looking at what folks have been have
been saying there by the way if you
really want to retweet something that is
extremely triggering to a lot of
right-wing lunatic Christians eight
hours ago I asked why are Luna
Christian's even invited to speak about
coronavirus we should listen to doctors
and scientists not lunatic Christian
pastors real quick here's Jerry Falwell
Jr suggesting kim jeong-hoon might have
invented coronavirus as a bio weapon can
and the mullah report didn't work and
and article 25 didn't work and so maybe
now this is their their next my article
25 he's referring to the 25th amendment
their next attempt to get trump but but
i had a the owner of a restaurant asked
me last night he said you remember the
north korean leader promised a Christmas
present for for america back rent back
in december could it be they got
together with china and this is that
president i don't know how it really is
some random guy in a restaurant set it
to a religious nut christian so now he's
presenting it on fox news something
strange going on well jerry so regarding
the fact that you're going to continue
to have classes yeah
skipping over completely that absolute
insanity okay other super chats coming
in joe kracken berg says i don't know I
don't care what Biden says when I know
he won't do it
the Beckman ATAR says if I remember
correctly a few months ago Biden floated
the idea of serving as a one-term
president do you think that's still the
case or no I was wondering about that
and I have no idea whatsoever died
famous says David why did Biden cough so
much into his hands you know I didn't
notice that actually I didn't notice
that we'll c-137 says do you think Trump
would use kovat 19 to try to delay the
election I'm increasingly wondering if
he will do that that is not a crazy
question I'm increasingly wondering that
and I hope that the answer is no unless
actual public health experts say it
should be done in which case we're going
to have a real real conundrum on our
hands all right that does it for me
tonight it has been quite a long night
we have a full day tomorrow including
the first day of this decentralized
David Pakman show production so that
does it for me thank you for joining me
we will have so much more tomorrow and
then Tuesday and then a live stream with
election results on Tuesday evening I
hope to see you then